microsoft announced their play anywhere  program back at e3 but now they've  confirmed that the service will apply to  all Microsoft Studios games going  forward I'm Tony and this is your cross  playing game spot news update it might  not be a big surprise but it's now  confirmed that every new Microsoft  Studios game will be available on both  xbox one and pc the play anywhere  program kicks off in September with  recore then followed up by other games  like Forza horizon 3 in Gears of War for  by any of those digitally on one  platform and you'll have access to it on  the other we've got a full list of the  currently confirmed play anywhere games  up on gamespot this news should be  especially interesting to Halo fans  since it apparently confirms that the  inevitable halo 6 will be available on  PC seems like the play anywhere program  is doing some pretty good work to keep  up with all the latest on halo Microsoft  and everything in between you're already  in the right place